a to 192 david p is our voicemail number
we have a voicemail here about
republican welfare states take a listen
to this you know the best ways to piss
off republicans is to point out how
every single one of their states is on
welfare i get into on my argument for
republican trolls all the time we called
snowflake this snowflake that whenever i
want to end the argument i always point
out first aid is on welfare provided by
my stage yeah I don't know if it's every
Republican state but many Republican
states are the beneficiaries of federal
government welfare and they would be
basically economically not viable if it
weren't for the fact that they are
subsidized by blue states so I don't
know if the caller is a hundred percent
right but the general point here is
absolutely accurate and reminds me of
that quote get your government hands off
of my Medicare
absolutely startled inform the Holder
let's a little misunderstanding about
how basic government and your state
government is functioning we've had a
great bonus show for you today I'm out
of time just trust me folks it's a good
one you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership